the married murder suspects who made a  dramatic escape from custody more than  two weeks ago have been recaptured  authorities announced overnight that  Blaine and Susan Barksdale were arrested  in Arizona they're accused of killing a  Tucson man and intentionally setting  fire to his home in April before fleeing  the state in May law enforcement found  and arrested the couple in Henryetta New  York but as a security van took the  couple back to Arizona last month they  overpowered guards in Utah and escaped  the FBI was involved in the ensuing  manhunt and earlier this week the US  Marshal Service added Blaine Barksdale  to its 15 most wanted list police plan  to announce details of the arrests later  this morning